how do you deal with the unknown by  recognizing i have no choice  right yeah cause that's actually life  zero people exist are you scared like do  you ever fear the unknown nope because  i'm confident yeah  like i'm not scared because i know i can  handle anything i'm grateful for  everything i've got and i never envy and  want anything else i'm an optimist if  something bad happens tomorrow i would  default into thinking well i'm so  grateful that i've had it for this long  yeah instead of like why did it go away  it's all about the way you think about  it 100 and you need to chip away at that  and you need to realize what's practical  or not  you